ho finalmente siamo giunti alla parte
peggiore da merita da quando ho iniziato
a fare i video di 10 minuti su happy
meals sapevo che sarebbe arrivato questo
momento che il più infimo meschino
bastardi perché molto semplicemente oggi
andremo a fare il 10 minuti mila 15
minuti di è più simile a fare più
livelli possibili cimenti di escape the
box possiamo cominciare ragazzi 321
garros
allora vamp e allora gli sky box sono
per chi non li conoscesse ok questa è la
fantastica se veramente così la
fantastica ma se l'ho presa delibera
sono posto vinto ho vinto ho vinto non
c'e non c'e la vittoria una vittoria ma
ho vinto già vittore movente sono
scappato dalla scatola descritte boca
non posso fermarmi la gara che essere
video un cazzo e quindi devo muovere il
culo prima di che sono perdo tempo
vagoni perfetto 2 nel primo luce della
vittoria quindi andava bene così
il terreno rispetto alla vittoria ma lei
non arrivava quindi va 1 stavo dicendo
iscritte box è perché c'è questa musica
famigliola di sottofondo l'abbiamo tolta
però ho perso del tempo più di 100
iscritti the fox ragazzi è un perché
l'odio l'odio così tanto perché mi mette
l'ansia perché tu sei a adesso vi faccio
vedere come sono livello tu sei a un
passo a un passo e ter è nuovo abbia
meglio l'unico diverso adesso vi faccio
vedere questo l'unico diverso ma che
sfiga
ve lo faccio vedere con le scritte botes
fatto dei 100 c'è quelli normali
ok maledizione questa è difficilissimo
perché mi sono bloccato al più di pepe e
giusta m bravo che c'è il culo molle
bravissimo vi faccio vedere perché tu
sei letteralmente a un passo dalla
vittoria che li sotto e c'è un filino di
vetro a coprire vivo ma no c'è un figlio
di vetro tra te e il traguardo
e tutto ciò che devi fare distruggerlo
ea mi mette ansia questo movimento
il movimento di spasmi per rompere il
vetro mi mettete quindi non volevo
arrivare questo momento del pareggio
dieci minuti di guanti e scope dieci
minuti perché sapevo che mi avrebbero
ansia però come sempre dobbiamo arrivare
a linee a qualche episodio estremi sto
gioco di merda che abbiamo personaggio
perché non lo sa che veramente piccola e
una non uno shock non riesce a spaccare
niente perché è troppo piccolo padre
liuc è abbastanza grande ma al culo
molle quindi uno sconto stiamo 8 minuti
poco meno quindi dai non è male come
punta il ragazzo anche andando bene
considerando cosa ho sprecato quattro
secondi perché avevo tolto la musica no
no ai fori con il demonio
ok perfetto perfetto l'effetto non è
vero mai perfetto
spero finisca questo video molto in
fretta mi dà troppo fastidio ragazzi
cioè questo questo continuo movimento di
culo avanti indietro per fine estate al
vetro vita troppo facendo cioè io rendo
fatti quando li faccio nei video normali
schede box appena finisco nico ringrazio
il cielo che do altri vedi da fare
quindi per me fare il 10 miti questo è
una tortura dai guarda quanto di ma
guarda quanto rimane di lei tra
pochissimo avevo quello che mi da
provideo crostone into you not passa 69
per cento
mao davano laico ancora al 7 minuti
comunque nessuno in questo video due
punti io che dico vadano o che predisse
a questo l'ho neanche rotto non sono
morto ma non mi hai fatto arrivare al
traguardo quindi ha dato un po meno di
stazzema lecco ho detto l'ex top quindi
devi tirare testate d'estate soffrivo
sfondano la daunia separatismo da lei
non ci credo dallo zio sei vivo questo
momento ragazzi che non vicino meglio
arrivare qua abituare a quanto ci sto
mettendo lopresto vetro e non ho più
tempo ci pensate
pensate conterà difficile su diverse e
propri
dai ma che non 5 tutti 40 veloce 9
luglio che aveva perso un'ora e mezza
non non si può rompere questo scusate
questo non si può
ci ho messo un'ora
c'era la tattica c'era la tattica
tattica però mai giocato quarta tappa
evidenti serio non è problema migliorata
tanto di tenere la calma però è proprio
difficile gestire la mia rabbia 2000
faziosi livelli questo è un crepa like
quando saltiamo ragazzi non lo conto ma
era un global ai più questo è perché non
si poteva vincere a livelli che ti
facciamo tardi volta 5 stelle non il
partito dal livello 5 stelle e chi
facciamo funziona la bomba ma
puntualmente non funziona quindi con
l'altro non lo contiamo poi non lo conto
pro mi ha fatto perdere cinque secondi 5
secondi per quello ragazzi e 5 secondi
perché ho tolto la musica di recupero
alla fine quindi alla fine avrà dieci
secondi di bonus
scusatemi se mi permetto ma c'è la
musica dice che mi dà fastidio perso
tempo e lì ho perso tempo perché non
livello infattibile quindi porca vacca
sporca dai sono morto bastan ragazzi
veramente difficile
e queste accuse arrivate la parte
veramente difficile che spiego dopo un
po che kg testate i m tipo così il mio
cervello inizia a diventare un po della
consistenza del d'azienda doc nord
quindi è normale che
non riesca più a fare sta roba però
questo è facile poi spesso basta dire a
testate mido la spinta dal muro così no
no non vi aspetta numerosi e bellissimo
e dalla facilissimo ma riesco sempre la
mia spinta dal muro non esposta volta
che mi serve sono ancora vivo io non
sono vivo
volevo darmi la spinta dal muro c'è
proprio i pasti jam in orizzontale ma
non riesce ad arrivare al muro ci
pensate
sono partito bene perfetto
sono partito bene e ho continuato di
mere non so come sia possibile sono
uscito a partire perfettamente gli di
continuo fa vomitare
ho fatto vomitare io porca vacca change
caractère non lo so che veramente
piccolo questo si è incastrato con le
gambe
quanti quanti sbaglio ho fatto questo
video che non erano contemplati poi
recupera i 10 secondi alpini ragazzi ve
l'ho detto
[Musica]
succede cosa succede
dai mio dio ma continuiamo così
no ragazzi avete veramente problema sei
perfetto perfetto sei vivo sei vivo sei
vivo siriu dei salutati ma per che cosa
fai tutta la vita fare con un pazzo con
tuo figlio bravissimo
questo che voglio da te porto lemonia
due minuti e 20 le 2 e 30 che dovrebbe
previsioni a fine papa o no siccome lo
spacco sto vetro a testa ti rendi conto
che è rimasto un filo che poteva
incazzarmi leggermente dai due minuti da
sfruttare tv box neon svolse in coma per
favore non c è veramente difficile c'è
scritto anche ok gli ho dato una fise
lata non c'è detto zio non c'è cassini
vetro un check up
sarò ancora vivo tutto ok
babbo natale di perché non ci ho pensato
prima babbo natale dovrebbe avere un
night bomber colo li bellissimo vincia 6
migliore play nostra famiglia io a zero
noi come sede rocks due testate al vetro
veloce grandissimo bisogno di preso
verso la vita ho fatto l'inizio da dio
la metà da schifo e la fine da dio cioè
pensate cielo benedetto da dio è nota ma
con minuto c'è poi forse è la volta in
cui riesco a fare di più livelli in
dieci minuti di incredibile guarda qua
perfetto cabochon cos'è sta roba allora
le scritte box non è uniscape the box
questo non vale altri dieci minuti e 10
secondi di recupero alla fine altri
secondi la mi aveva fatto perdere tempo
devo recuperare 20 secondi dai avete
fatto per tempo con livelli che non
c'entrano né escludo 2 dal conteggio
finale ma altri dieci secondi dai mi fai
perde tempo per niente
[Musica]
trovate la tattica dello sfondamento
fondamento sfondamento un nuovo termine
scogna tous coniato un nuovo termine
nuovo quindi per tutta la famiglia in un
video senza tagli perché i tagli non mi
posso fare sognato soprattutto se pare
che il parente malvagio del cognato
vanno avanti 20 secondi a recuperare la
fine lo ricordo
no questo è stato un errore mio quindi
non di recupero io ci credo
se non avessi fatto quella cazzata lì ok
ok siamo sullo zero ma ancora venti
secondi di bonus con i medi dai ancora
qui rai ce la faccia come qualcuno forse
lui fanno i tempi simo j 5 secondi dico
bravo a posto va bene da vengono avendo
letto basta ho recuperato anche dei miei
sbagli va bene allora contiamo e
sottraiamo poi per due perché due
livelli non contano quindi 1234 questo
non conta velo contiamo lo stesso per la
fine tolgo 2 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 pd
6 se 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
meno 2 che non andavano perché erano i
livelli page 26 la fefa ragazzi sono
riusciti a fare 26 livelli in dieci
minuti questo non è male c'è in realtà
pensavo fosse il rialzo partito dicendo
che era sarebbe stato peggiore dilata go
è mentalmente ma come risultato no solo
soddisfatto si poteva fare di meglio
assolutamente sì ragazzi secondo me se
non mi fossi impappinato all'inizio sarà
arrivato almeno almeno a 30
nella migliore delle ipotesi anche a 35
ragazzi però fatto 26
non è per niente male però se vi sia
piaciuto fatemi sapere se riuscito a
fare di meglio
cosa c'entri prigione solo questo vi
piace iscrivere al canale e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo bisogna qui e
non sclero è ricordatevi anche di
salutare il vostro sognato che comunque
smettiamola di circa gatte bella ragazza
[Musica]